CHRISTIAN PLAGEMANN:
Good morning, everyone,
to this morning
session on Cardboard,
virtual reality for Android.
I've got with me here David Coz.
He's a software engineer at
Google's Cultural Institute
in Paris.
My name is Christian Plagemann.
I'm a research
scientist and team
lead for physical interaction
research here in Mountain View.
And we have Boris Smus, who's
a prototyper software engineer
and researcher also in our
group in Mountain View.
So this talk is about
a piece of cardboard.
Or let's say what it
actually is about,
is about some surprising
things that your phone
can do when you just add a
little bit of extra equipment.
And for those of you
who've been here yesterday,
after the keynote
and in the afternoon,
they know of course exactly
what I'm talking about.
For those who are
watching from remote,
let me just a replay a
few moments of yesterday.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-We're going to hand each and
every one of you a cardboard.
-Here you go.
-There's a piece
of adhesive tape.
[CHATTER]
-Wow, that's great.
-Oh, dang.
-Oh, wow.
-Wow.
-Oh, fancy.
-I think I love this.
-Wow, that's crazy.
-Oh my god!
-Oh, this is incredible.
-Oh, that's insane.
-Oh, cool.
[GASP]
-Wow.
That's awesome.
-Cool.
That's fantastic.
--[GASP] It says "Fly to Space,"
when you look up into the sky.
[LAUGHTER]
-This is so [BLEEP] clever.
[END VIDEOPLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN PLAGEMANN: OK.
Here goes my clicker.
So what you got
yesterday, all of you,
were these simple
cardboard boxes.
And what that basically does is
you insert your phone into it,
and it kind of turns your
phone into a very basic
virtual reality headset.
And what you can
do with that is you
can look around and experience
content in another place,
whether it's real or artificial,
in a totally different way.
Like not on a small
postcard size,
but actually all around you.
And we are making
the hardware design
and an open-source
software toolkit
openly available to
everyone, because we
want people to get started.
There's a lot of development
in this area already,
and we want to really
kickstart a lot more of that.
And that's why we want to
get it into people's hands.
And to just to add a few
other surprising things that
happened yesterday, so just
two hours or three hours
after we posted our
designs on the website,
somebody actually
came up already
with their own
construction of it.
It's a little bit
rough around the edges.
[LAUGHTER]
But wait another two hours,
and on the first online store,
there was actually, you could
order Google's Cardboard VR
Tookit.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
And we actually express
ordered one yesterday.
So we kind of ran
out, so maybe we
can get some more to give
out at the conference,
but they haven't arrived yet.
We got the lenses people
can order on the store
through our friends
Durovis Dive,
and those actually all
sold out in 20 minutes.
So this is really
what we had hoped for,
just 100 times faster than
we kind of anticipated.
And the goal of this
talk today, which
is obviously brief for
a big topic like this,
is we want to give you
a rough overview of how
virtual reality on a mobile
phone works in principle.
We want to explain to you
how this project came about
and why we started it.
It was really like
a side project.
And most importantly
for you as developers,
we want to walk you through
our open source software
toolkit and a sample app, so
that you can start hacking
right away.
And with this, I hand
over to David Coz.
He actually started
this as a side project
six months ago in Paris.
This is David.
DAVID COZ: Thank you, Christian.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, everybody.
So the first thing to know
is that I'm a big VR fan.
I just love, you know,
the sense of immersion
it gives, the fact that you
can just look around you
in a very natural way at
all this content, be it
created content or virtual
reality, pure content.
And there's been
so much progress
in the space in
the past few years.
We have, obviously, Oculus
Rift doing a great job
at putting VR back
into the media
attention with an
awesome device.
And also, a trend of
mobile phone-based viewers,
like the Dorovis Dive or
other do-it-yourself projects.
And with my friend
Damien in Paris,
about six months ago, we
were really enthusiastic
about this progress,
and we're thinking,
how can we accelerate
this even more,
so that not just tech
addicts can experience VR,
but you know, anybody
with a smartphone?
So our idea was really to build
the simplest and cheapest way
of turning your smartphone
into A VR viewer.
And that's how we-- we
started to collaborate
about six months ago in
the Cultural Institute Lab
at our office in
Paris, which is,
you know, a lab space where
engineers and artists,
thinkers, can
collaborate on projects.
And we started to
really naturally try it
with cardboard,
because it's so easy.
And we know we cut some
cardboard into a box,
and quickly came up with
is really rough design.
Looks a bit like the one you
saw earlier, with Christian.
That really worked
well already, and I
decided to work on this
as 20% project, which
is a side project
you can do at Google.
And we used the laser cutter
to build the first batch
of almost identical goggles that
we showed around at the office.
People got really excited, so
I decided to take this with me
to our main office
here in Mountain View.
And that's how I met
Christian and his team.
And they got really
excited and enthusiastic
about this product,
and together we
decided to take it
a few steps further,
in terms of hardware
design-- also, the software
toolkit and the experiences.
And now actually
to run some demos,
I'm going to ask Boris to
build a headset for us.
So Boris, everyone
is watching you.
You have 30 seconds.
No pressure.
So while Boris is
assembling the viewer,
let me emphasize why we
actually chose cardboard
and we actually stick to it.
The first reason is
we wanted the viewer
to feel and look really simple.
Everybody's familiar
with cardboard.
And the idea there is
that your phone is really
the piece that does
the magic here.
Your phones are so
powerful, it was just
great to add this simple
viewer on top of it.
The second reason is we
want you guys to just take
scissors, staplers, and just
go crazy at it and modify it.
And it's just so natural
and easy with cardboard.
We put the plans online, if
you go to our main website.
And it's open for grabs.
Just go crazy at it and
send us your modifications.
We'll be really
happy to see them.
So Boris, a bit slower
than the rehearsal.
Yeah.
OK, great job, Boris.
[APPLAUSE]
So now that we have these
viewer, the question is,
what can we do with this?
And the first thing that
we got really excited about
is the possibility
to just go anywhere
on Earth, leveraging, of course,
the geodata we have at Google.
So we built this experience
with Google Earth,
using geodata that we have.
And Boris is going to take
you on a tour through this.
So you can see here the kind of
traditional VR screen settings,
with two screens,
one for each eye.
And you can see how
the display adapts
to the head movements in
a really reactive way.
Look at how Boris is moving,
and this is adapting quite fast.
So your phones are doing quite
a good job at this, actually.
And then using the magnet
clicker on the side
that we added, Boris can start
to fly around the mountains.
And it's one thing-- I guess
if you guys will try it.
It's one thing to
see it like this.
It's totally another
thing to try it,
because you have
this nice 3D effect.
And of course, here the cables
adjust for screen mirroring.
Otherwise, you can
just walk everywhere.
And Boris can also start to
look up and fly to space.
And from there, you can access
a selection of nice places
that we selected for you
guys-- and precached, actually,
so that we don't have
Wi-Fi problems at the I/O.
And now he just teleports
himself too Chicago
and can look around.
So we really like this idea of
virtually visiting any place.
And not only can
you visit a place,
but you can also use VR
to learn more about them.
And that was really
important for us,
for my team in the Cultural
Institute in Paris.
We wanted to build this
tour where you can, like,
take people, take even kids, to
learn more about these places.
So we used the Street
View data that we
acquired for this
really iconic place.
This is the Palace of
Versailles in France.
And you have a
charming local guide
that tells you stories
about this place,
and you can just
really look around.
It's a very nice way
of discovering content.
Another kind of
interesting thing we tried
is this YouTube integration,
where basically, it's
a massive-- yes, it's
flickering a bit.
Yeah.
It's a massive, giant
home theater room
where you have this big
screen in front of your eyes
so you can play videos.
And imagine it's like having
a giant screen just, like,
two feet from your face.
And we also kind of
made use of, you know,
all this space that
you have around you.
So it's a really
interesting use of VR,
where we put video
thumbnails, and by looking
at them-- whoops, something
went down, I think.
So by looking at them and
using the magnet clicker,
you can very naturally
select a video and play it.
It's a bit shaky.
So we're really excited about
this kind of integration.
We think we can-- we
have lots of product
at Google, lots of products.
We can use VR to kind of
enhance existing products.
And one similar such integration
we're really proud about
is Google Maps integration.
There's actually, right now,
as of today, integrations--
we have a Street View
VR mode for Street View.
There's something
wrong with the cables.
So you can basically
go anywhere where
we have Street View, pull
up the Street View data,
and then you double tap.
You double-tap on
the arrow icon,
and you have a
side-by-side screen
rendering of Street View.
So you can put this on
your Cardboard device
and get a really good
feel for the place.
And this actually works on any
other phone-based VR viewer.
So Durovis Dive,
Altergaze, any view.
So we're really
happy about this.
It's not just a demo anymore.
It's actually in a live product.
Another thing, as I
guess you noticed,
these were all
Android-based applications.
But you can also very
simply, very easily
build similar applications
with a browser.
And we have this set
of Chrome Experiments
that you can find
out on our website.
And this is just using
JavaScript and HTML5.
It's very easy with
libraries like Three.js.
So I encourage you to go on
our website and check out.
The source is absolutely
small and nice.
And it has nice music.
Here we don't have sound, but
you have nice, catchy music,
so try it.
So we have a couple
of more demos.
We don't have
really all the time
in the world to present them.
I wanted to
emphasize two things.
The first thing is the Photo
Sphere demo is really cool.
You take your Photo Sphere and
you can really naturally look
around at a place
you visited before.
I think it totally makes
sense with Photo Sphere.
The second thing is Windy Day.
They actually have
a booth right there
at I/O. I encourage
you to check it out.
They produced this really
nice storytelling movie
in a 3D space, and you
can just look around,
and depending on where
you're looking at,
the story progresses.
So yeah, again, we
really want to get
you inspired by all these
experiences and demos.
You can go on g.co/cardboard
and learn more about them,
get the plans for this viewer.
And more importantly,
we really want
you to build on top
of what we provide,
in terms of the viewer,
the toolkit, and the demos.
And Christian is going to tell
you more about how you do this.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN PLAGEMANN: So there's
really one important thing
we want to emphasize, which
is this is just a placeholder.
Like, this is a
piece of cardboard.
I think TechCrunch wrote
this very nicely yesterday.
Is that an Oculus?
Of course not.
It's cardboard.
But we think it can get you
started, like, fairly quickly.
So that's the point of it.
And kind of the
principles behind VR
are pretty uniformly the same.
And I just want to spend a few
minutes on describing those
to you, before Boris goes
into the coding part.
So what do you
need to actually do
to turn a phone
into a VR headset?
I want to describe three aspects
that we put into this viewer.
The one, obviously,
is the optics.
That's kind of one of
the crucial components.
The other one is you want to
interact with the experience,
so we built this little clicker.
And the NFC tag, which is a neat
little idea that lets a phone
go automatically from a phone
experience into a VR experience
and back, like, seamlessly.
So how does it work?
So imagine you rip off the
top, which you can easily
do-- you just need to build
another one then-- to basically
realize there are two holes,
and then at a certain distance,
there's the screen.
So what happens if the user
brings the device really
close to the eyes, your eyes
look through these holes
and you have a fairly wide field
of view through these holes.
And then what happens next
is when you put lenses
into these holes, that
basically concentrates
your wide field of view onto a
small image area on the screen,
like for the left eye
and for the right eye.
And "all," in quotation
marks, that you
have to do as
developers is render
images on these small
areas, left and right, that
make your brain believe
you're in a different place.
So that has to be very fast,
accurate, as high-resolution
as possible.
It has to be synchronized
well with your head motion.
So let's look a
little bit closer
into this rendering pipeline.
So imagine you want to put
the user into a virtual space.
One of the critical things
you need to know, of course,
is head where is
the user looking at?
And what we can do is, the
mobile phones, the recent ones
of the recent years, they
give you very nice, actually,
orientation tracking.
They have [INAUDIBLE].
And Android provides
you-- and all kind
of other mobile
operating systems, too,
or you write your own
libraries-- provide you
a way of integrating all
of these readings over time
and give you a relatively
fast stream of 3D orientation
estimates, like the [INAUDIBLE]
of where the device is headed.
So if you have those, you
can pick your favorite kind
of 3D environment, like library,
like OpenGL, for example,
and you can define the center
of this virtual universe
as the head of the user.
And then you basically
put two cameras,
for the left eye and the
right eye, at eye distance
on a virtual rig, and
you orient these cameras
based on these orientation
estimates from the phone.
And then you do just
the regular rendering
that you do anyways for
any kind of 3D application.
You render one for the
left, one for the right eye,
and you get these
streams of images out.
And obviously,
you want to adjust
the field of view of the camera
and kind of the general set-up
to match the geometry
of your viewer.
One last thing that you need to
do before you put that actually
onto the screen is you have
to adjust for lens distortion.
So because this lens kind of
widens your field of view,
you get this distortion
effect, which
is called the
pincushion distortion.
Which basically means
that outer-image areas
are enlarged more
than central ones.
Luckily, what you can
do is you can come up
with a model for this.
You can kind of fit a
function either analytically,
because you know how
this device is set up
and what the lenses are,
or you just measure that.
Using a camera and a
calibration pattern,
you can fit a function
to this, and then you
can invert this function.
So this means if you write a
shader that basically takes
a regularly-rendered image
and distorts with this, what
is called barrel
distortion, this
has the effect that if you
put that through a lens,
the undistorted image
arrives in your eyes.
And that's how you basically
render this entire thing.
The next aspect I
want to talk about
is you have these
images on your eye,
and they kind of track
your head motion,
but how do interact with them?
You kind of hid the
touchscreen in this viewer,
and you don't necessarily
want to stick your fingers in
and kind of obstruct your view.
So we kind of had
this neat little idea
of putting magnets inside.
There's a fixed
magnet on the inside,
and there's this
movable magnetic ring
on the outside, which
if you move this magnet,
you can basically detect
the change of magnetic field
with a magnetometer.
So kind of what
drives the compass.
And I want to show
you real quick
how beautiful these signals are.
We were kind of surprised
how clean they are.
So what you see
here is somebody--
you see three lines, which
is the X, Y, and Z direction,
like three coordinates of
the magnetometer, which
kind of tells you how the
magnetic field is oriented.
And you see when I move
this magnet, what kind
of beautiful signals we get.
And so you can write a very
simple classifier that picks up
the up and down and translates
that into an input event.
The downside of this, of course,
is you're losing the compass.
So inside this experience,
we don't know, anymore,
where kind of north is.
Because we always think, oh,
north is where the magnet is.
But we figured
universal environments,
it's much more important you
have some way of interacting.
Like flying, not flying,
starting/stopping a video,
opening up a box, or
whatever you want to do.
So that's a
trade-off, and you're
completely free to come up
with other awesome ideas
to interact.
The last thing I want to
mention is the NFC tag.
So we have just a
regular NFC tag--
we used a fairly
big one so that it
fits different phones-- where
we put a special URL on it
that our framework handles, that
basically tells the phone, hey,
I'm now in the 3D viewer.
Your app wants to maybe
switch into an immersive mode.
So the long-term
vision for this is,
for example, you
have a YouTube app
and you're watching some kind
of talk or a sports game.
It's nice, but when you
put it into the viewer,
you have the exact same sports
game, but you can look around.
And you can hop from,
like, player to player,
or all these kind of things.
So you can think about
all kinds of applications
that can go seamlessly back
and forth and in and out.
That's where kind of
also this mobile concept
is a bit different from these
really head-mounted concepts.
But with a stapler,
you can, of course,
transform this
into head-mounted.
And this is all nice.
It's not that super
difficult to do
this kind of
rendering in type end.
But we wanted to make
it as easy as possible,
so we packaged, basically,
the hard pieces up
into one open-source
library, which
you can find on our website.
And Boris will walk you
through kind of the APIs
and how you can start coding.
[APPLAUSE]
BORIS SMUS: Thanks, Christian.
Check, check,
check, check, check.
All right.
So as you saw, we
demoed a bunch of things
at the beginning of the talk.
Some of them were
written in Android,
but the coin collector example
was actually written in Chrome
using Three.js, which
is a lightweight wrapper
around WebGL to
make developing 3D
applications for
the web super easy.
And we used, also,
JavaScript events
to track the position
of the user's head.
So it's an easy
way to get started.
But of course, with Android,
we can get a little bit
closer to the metal.
So the toolkit that we
are open-sourcing today
is an Android-based VR toolkit,
as Christian introduced,
designed to make developing
VR applications as
easy as possible.
So today, if you go
to g.co/cardboard,
what you get is the
soon-to-be open-sourced--
we're working on a couple
of tweaks-- VR toolkit,
so this is just a JAR file, and
a sample that we'll be talking
about more throughout
this session.
So what is the sample
we're going to be building?
It is a treasure
hunt application.
So the idea here is there's
an object hidden somewhere
inside your field
of view around you,
and your goal is to
find it and collect it.
The way you collect it is, of
course, through the magnet,
and the more objects you
get, the more points you get.
Very simple.
So we'll start with
our favorite IDE.
Get the JAR from the website.
Put it in as a
regular dependency.
And the first thing we do is
create our own custom activity.
But instead of extending from
the default Android activity,
we'll extend from the
Cardboard activity,
which the toolkit provides.
This does a few things.
Firstly, the screen
is forced to stay on.
The screen is placed
in landscape mode,
and we hide all of
the UI on the top
and on the bottom
of the phone screen,
typically the navigation bar
and the notification bar.
We also disable the volume
keys, because often you
might accidentally trigger them.
These are, of course, just
defaults and can be overridden,
but it's a good starting point.
still, we have nothing
on the screen for now.
So what we'll do is
we'll create an instance
of the CardboardView,
which is a view that
extends from
GLSurfaceView, which
is the standard way that you
render 3D content for Android.
The way we'll do this
is in our activity,
we override the onCreate method
with a series of simple steps.
Here we find the view
in our layout hierarchy.
Next, we tell the
Cardboard activity
that we should be using
this particular view,
set the renderer,
and we're good to go.
So before I go too deep
into the renderer itself,
let me quickly recap what
Christian just told you
about the rendering pipeline.
So there's four basic steps.
First, we need to
estimate eye positions,
to figure out where
to place the two
virtual cameras in our scene.
Next, we render the scene.
So we take the world
space and project it
into eye space for both eyes.
Then each eye needs to have
its lens distortion corrected.
And finally, we place
the two displays side
by side in landscape
stereo mode.
As far as what the
toolkit provides for you,
it's actually quite a lot.
So the first thing,
we have a head tracker
that we're releasing.
This also includes an eye model.
So we have a basic
distance estimation
between two average
human eyes, so we
know where to place the cameras.
Once the scene is rendered,
we correct for lens distortion
based on the optical properties
of the Cardboard device.
And finally, we place
the images side by side,
leaving you only the rendering.
The second step is the only
thing you need to worry about.
So to do that, we make
a custom renderer,
the TreasureHuntRenderer
here, and you
can see it implements
an interface
that our framework provides.
And there's two methods you
need to care about here.
The first one is onNewFrame.
This gets called every
time a frame is rendered,
and it takes in the
HeadTransform, which
is roughly the heading of
where the user is looking.
So here we'll save it
for later, because we're
going to need to know if the
user's looking at the treasure
or not.
The other thing we can do in
onNewFrame is update the model.
So typically there's
an update/draw cycle
in many graphics applications.
So we'll just increment
a time count here.
So that's the first method.
The next is we need to
implement onDrawEye.
And this gets called
twice for each frame,
once for the left eye
and once for the right.
And, of course, we
pass in the position
of each eye, or of the
eye order rendering,
which includes a
bunch of parameters
that you need to draw a scene.
So as you expect in
a GL application,
first we set up our matrices.
So we go from View
and from Perspective
to Model-View-Projection matrix,
and then we draw the scene.
Now it's important that
we do this operation
as quickly as possible,
because introducing any latency
into the system can have
undesirable effects, let's say.
I'll go more into this later.
So at this point, we've
rendered our scene.
Here you can see our
treasure, which is a cube.
And it's, you know, it's there.
But of course, once we
pass on to the framework,
we take the scene, transform
it by the head orientation,
by each eye-- so each eye
has a separate camera--
and we apply the lens distortion
and place the results side
by side.
So we have our
treasure, teasing us,
but so far, we haven't
figured out how to collect it.
It's very simple.
So as Christian mentioned, we
have these magnetometer traces.
And we've provided
a way to detect
this pull-and-release
gesture very easily.
All you need to do
is, in the activity,
implement onCardboardTrigger.
And for our application
here, we can
see the code is straightforward.
If the user's looking at the
treasure, then we pick it up.
Otherwise, we tell
them some instructions.
But lastly, we want
to somehow emphasize--
or I want to
emphasize-- that we want
to provide user feedback
here, since we want
to know if the magnet
pull was actually
detected by the framework.
And a good way to
provide this feedback
is through a
vibration-- but make
sure it's a short one, because
long vibrations with the phone
so close to your face can
be a little bit jarring--
or a quick AlphaBlend,
just a transparency blend.
OK, the last piece of
input is the NFC tag.
And as we mentioned
earlier, it's
an easy way to make these
amphibious applications that
can adjust to being inserted or
removed from the VR enclosure.
So in our example, for the
purpose of this illustration,
we may want to make our
treasure hunt app also
work when you take
it out of Cardboard.
In that case, we want to
present not a stereo view,
but a single view.
So the toolkit provides
this very easy flag
that you can toggle,
which is VRModeEnabled.
And all you do is
you flip that flag
and go between the
stereo and regular modes.
Of course, the NFC tag has
something encoded in it.
So you don't need to use
our framework to detect it.
You can just use
a regular intent
filter, as you would in
an Android application,
to know if the tag has
been scanned or not.
Now another benefit of
having this tag in the device
is that if you want to make
hardware modifications-- which
we hope you do--
then you can encode
these changes inside the NFC.
So for example, you
want to increase
the field of view of the lenses.
You can change the
parameters of the distortion
that you need to apply.
Or you want to increase the
interpupillary distance, which
is the technical term for the
distance between your eyes.
You can also encode
that in the NFC tag.
And this way the toolkit
can provide the best
possible rendering even
for your modified device.
OK, so we've talked a bit
about using the framework.
And we've used this
framework extensively
over the course of the
last couple months.
So what we've learned, though,
is that quite obviously,
building an Android
application is
very different from
building a VR application.
So I want to leave you with
three principles which we've
found from this
development process.
The first one is very
well-known in the VR community,
and it is to keep physical
motion and visual motion
closely coupled.
The idea is that the brain has
two systems, roughly speaking,
to detect motion.
One is the vestibular, which is
sort of your sense of balance,
and the other is
your visual, which
is, obviously, your eyesight.
And if the systems
are not in sync,
then your illusion of reality
in a VR environment can go away,
and you can even
get motion sick.
So we've found that
it helps, for example,
to relieve this
problem, to place
the viewer in a fixed position.
Let them look around.
Or if you want to
create motion, then
make them move forward
at a constant velocity
in the direction of view.
There are probably other
ways of doing this,
but these two
things, we've found,
make it a pretty good experience
that's not very sickening.
So the other thing is you
need to keep latency down,
as I mentioned in the
onDrawEye discussion,
because having
high latency really
takes away from this illusion.
The second idea is to
keep the user's head free.
So the YouTube VR
adaptation that you saw
showed the user positioned
inside a movie theater,
as opposed to placing the movies
strictly in front of their eyes
and sticking to
them when they move.
So the idea here is
that we want to create
an immersive environment,
and this, in practice,
seems to work a lot better
than just putting things
in screenspace.
Lastly, really take advantage
of the giant field of view
that Cardboard gives you.
And essentially what
we're giving you
is a 80-degree FOV right off the
bat, which is like being a foot
or two away from a
50-inch TV screen.
Not only that, you can look
around in any direction.
So you have this infinite
virtual screen around you.
And it really helps to
take advantage of this.
So I want to emphasize
that it's still
very early days for
virtual reality.
And our toolkit is
just the beginning.
It's just the tip
of the iceberg,
and there's a lot
more to explore.
Obviously smartphones have
tons of additional sensors
that we haven't tapped into.
There's a microphone present.
There's an accelerometer.
I've Seen demos where
you can detect jumps.
You can, of course,
interface with accessories
like game pads and
steering wheels, et cetera.
And also, I'm particularly
excited about combining this 3D
immersive video experience with
a sound experience, as well.
So imagine wearing a pair of
stereo headphones, in addition.
So of course, also, we have
a camera in the device.
So I want to call
David up to show us
a demo of something that
uses the camera, as well.
So David is going to fire up
a demonstration in which he
can manipulate a
virtual object in front
of him using the camera
inside of the phone.
So this is using the
Qualcomm Vieuphoria library,
which is a pretty
advanced object--
DAVID COZ: Whoops.
BORIS SMUS: A pretty advanced
configuration library.
And we've augmented our demo.
DAVID COZ: Sorry for that.
BORIS SMUS: No problem.
So anyway, the
idea here is David
will have-- actually, your
Cardboard comes with a QR
code, which this demo
will be showing you.
So essentially, when
you look at the QR code,
you can manipulate this piece
of cardboard in front of you.
So give us a second here
as we try to get it going.
So as you can see, it's just
a slightly modified version
of the app.
So you can see, as I move
this piece of cardboard,
the Vieuphoria library is
actually tracking the marker.
DAVID COZ: And I can still look
around in a very natural way.
BORIS SMUS: So we
can combine-- by just
having a simple
marker and a camera,
we can get this
really cool effect.
So imagine if you were
to combine our technology
with a Tango device,
which gives you
six degrees of tracking
in almost any environment.
Great.
Thanks, David.
So with that, definitely
check out our website,
where you can download
the toolkit itself.
It'll be open source soon.
We have docs.
We have a tutorial
for you to get
started that goes
through this sample.
Also, tons of samples,
including Chrome ones,
on chromeexperiments.com,
and Android ones, the ones
that we showed you today, which
is available in the Play Store.
And if you want to hack
on the physical model,
then we have all the
plans there for you.
So we can't wait to see
what you come up with.
Thank you all for
listening, and we'll
take about five
minutes of questions.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN PLAGEMANN:
So for the questions,
if you could walk up to
the microphones, that'd
probably be easiest.
BORIS SMUS: Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Oh, this is so cool.
I really love it.
I just had a quick
question for you.
I hope you can hear me.
The trigger that
you had, you seem
to have kind of like tied
it to the magnetic thing.
So I was wondering, is
it possible to do it
through double-clicks
and things just
by using the one
waveform you have?
Or does that need the
framework to actually support
those methods?
BORIS SMUS: Right, so
thank you for the question.
The question was about
supporting double-clicks
using the magnet clicker.
And the answer is
we can do a lot.
The problem is right
now we're using
a calibrated magnetometer,
which is the thing that's
used mostly for the compass.
And the thing with the
calibrated magnetometer
is it calibrates every so
often, which is this event,
and it drastically
messes up the signals.
So a lot of modern phones--
I think the Nexus 4 and 5--
have an uncalibrated
magnetometer, which you can use
and it does not have
this calibration event.
So with that out of the
equation, we can do a lot more.
We've even thought about,
like, having a full joypad
on the side of the
cardboard device,
with the magnet able to
move in any direction.
So this is something
we can do once we've
switched to-- once
enough phones, I guess,
have uncalibrated magnetometers.
AUDIENCE: Can you
elaborate-- is there
any way for users to readily
generate pictorial content?
For instance, if you're
taking a vacation
and you want to
capture, what do you do?
CHRISTIAN PLAGEMANN: Yeah.
So one thing we haven't
demoed right here,
but you should come up to the
Sandbox and really try it out,
is the Photo Sphere viewer.
So there's actually an app
that someone in our team
wrote that can actually show you
photo spheres in this viewer.
So you can actually take
those with your device,
and it actually takes the
local files from your device,
and that works well.
And of course, you could
come up with a picture view
just for regular pictures
that-- just very large.
And there's actually, the app
has an intent filter already,
so you can just click on
any photo sphere in the web,
for example, and it would
launch that particular viewer,
or give you the option.
BORIS SMUS: Yes?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, two
questions real quick.
One is I know there's a lot
of 3D content on YouTube.
Might this just
become a good way
to view that
stereoscopic content?
Right now, it looked
like it was 2D content
in the examples you had.
Is that right?
DAVID COZ: Yep.
Yeah, so those were 2D
videos, just regular videos.
But it's true that
you have a lot
of side-by-side
videos on YouTube.
That's actually how
we kind of proved
that this concept was
working, was putting a YouTube
side-by-side video and
have the depth effect.
So I yeah, the YouTube
team might want to do this
in the future, but we cannot
really comment on this,
I guess, now.
It's a bit too early.
AUDIENCE: OK.
CHRISTIAN PLAGEMANN:
It's a natural thing.
Like it's very clearly
possible, and there are actually
apps on the store that do this.
AUDIENCE: And the
other question is
it seems like a
compass would be really
great to have in these
kinds of situation,
especially for
navigation-type tools.
Might we see a future
version of this
that just uses voice commands to
navigate instead of the magnet
to click?
BORIS SMUS: So the question
was, can we replace the magnet
with voice commands in order
to free up the compass?
AUDIENCE: Right.
BORIS SMUS: I think--
so voice commands can
be a bit unwieldy
for a quick action.
I mean, it's certainly
something to explore.
I mean, there's certainly
a microphone in the device.
So you can do so much more.
Like one of the things
that we thought about
was combining a tap on the
side, the accelerometer impulse,
with the microphone
signature of a tap.
So you can imagine doing all
sorts of different input modes
that would free up the magnet,
or free up the magnetometer,
for the compass.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah,
there are many ways.
One particular reason why
we didn't look at speech
was we give it out to
6,000 I/O attendees,
and everyone tries
to speech-control it,
then it gets a bit loud.
AUDIENCE: Could you manipulate
objects with your hands?
Have you tried that?
CHRISTIAN PLAGEMANN:
Yeah, of definitely.
AUDIENCE: I know you
did the QR Code, but--
CHRISTIAN PLAGEMANN:
I mean, take
a gesture-recognition library,
like you can recognize
the finger, you could
do these kind of things.
AUDIENCE: But it is
possible with the kit
that you put out today?
CHRISTIAN PLAGEMANN: No,
it's not in the kit already,
but there are many
ways to do this.
It's again-- I mean, it's
computer vision, right?
So you need to detect hands,
need to detect gestures,
and it's a regular
computer vision problem.
But actually, the cameras
in these are really good.
BORIS SMUS: There's also
some interesting prototypes
with the Oculus, for example,
and a Leap attached to it,
where you get a full
hand-tracker in front of you.
So you could look
into that, as well.
AUDIENCE: So there's no
[INAUDIBLE] reference.
How do you guys compensate?
Do you guys have any
compensation for the drift?
Because over time, like when
you're rotating sometimes,
and when you come back, it's
not in the same location.
Does the experience--
DAVID COZ: So the question
is about heading reference?
Like, yeah--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because over
time, your [INAUDIBLE] has--
DAVID COZ: Yeah, so it's
true that right now, we
don't have any reference,
because the compass is
kind of modified by the magnet.
So you can have this problem.
It depends a lot on
the phones, actually,
on the kind of calibration
that you have in your sensors.
It seems that on, for example,
recent phones, like Nexus 5K,
it doesn't drift so much.
But on all the phones
we tried, there
was kind of a significant drift.
So it's something that we
want to work on in the future.
BORIS SMUS: Are
you guys planning
on working also
position tracking
using just a 2D camera?
That would be a great
Tango integration, right?
So Tango does 6D tracking,
just with the reference
of the scene around you.
DAVID COZ: We actually built
a Tango-compatible Cardboard
device.
It's very easy.
Like you just need to increase
the width of the Cardboard.
CHRISTIAN PLAGEMANN:
And actually, the 2D
camera itself can provide
a pretty good, actually,
drift compensation.
So you can actually-- I mean,
you track features over time.
And then usually, these
drifts are very, very slow,
so usually they
accumulate over time.
Like these are
usually not big drifts
that are kind of showing--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
just, like, depending
how fast the camera can
detect the features, then?
CHRISTIAN PLAGEMANN: Uh, sure.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Windy Day is
fantastic on the Cardboard.
I was wondering if
you expect to get
the rights to the other
Spotlight Stories?
CHRISTIAN PLAGEMANN: Oh, we were
absolutely, absolutely amazed
by what the-- like we talked
directly to the Spotlights
team, and it was actually
the Spotlights team, like
the [INAUDIBLE] team in
the previous presentation,
that integrated all this
tech into the Cardboard,
and it works so well.
And I'm pretty sure they would
be more than happy to integrate
their others, as well.
DAVID COZ: The limitation
here was just the size,
because we embed all the
assets in the application.
So it was just a
question of size.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BORIS SMUS: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: One of the things that
came to mind as an alternative
to your magnetic button--
which I think is very clever,
but I'd really like
the magnetometer.
One of the things
I saw at AWE was,
what you can buy online for $20,
is a little pocket Bluetooth
game controller.
So I think that would
be a good thing.
And then I'd like to know when
you think you'll have here
your Cardboard Eyetracker ready.
Because I think
that's a good thing.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTIAN PLAGEMANN:
Yeah, that'd be nice, too.
It's tricky.
We thought about it.
Like using the
inward-facing cameras.
Like one of the major
design problems with this
is there's so many
different phones out there.
Like to basically, just to
find a hole that kind of fits
all the outward-facing
cameras, and to kind of find
the right form factor
that fits most,
that was already challenging.
And now if we want to come
up with the optics that
project the inward-facing
into your eyes,
it's a bit more work.
Oh, but totally agree.
Would be an amazing input.
BORIS SMUS: OK.
That's it.
Thank you very much, guys.
CHRISTIAN PLAGEMANN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]